منذ ما يقرب من 40 عامًا ، أدرك الأطفال
أنهم عندما يرون هذا الصندوق الأحمر الكبير ،
فإنهم سيحصلون على
وجبة خاصة من وجبة ماكدونالدز السعيدة عندما تم تقديمها لأول مرة
في عام 1979 ، احتوت وجبة هابي ميل على
هامبرغر وبطاطا مقلية بالجبن
وملفات تعريف الارتباط بأمان لتقول السعادة
لم تكن الوجبة صحية للغاية ، ولكن منذ ذلك الحين
، اتخذ عملاق الوجبات السريعة خطوات صغيرة
نحو وجبة أطفال أكثر تغذية في
عام 1984 ، قدمت الشركة McNugget
كبديل للحوم الحمراء بعد
20 عامًا ، أضاف ماكدونالدز بعض
الخيارات الصحية بما في ذلك شرائح التفاح
والحليب  وعصير التفاح في عام 2014 ،
قدمنا الفراولة كخيار جانبي ، ك
ا أنها أزلت ال
واد الحافظة الاصطناعية من قطعها الصغيرة وا
تبدلت خيارات الحليب والعصير بن
خة قليلة الدسم وأقل معالجة بحلول عام 2022 ، و
أمل سلسلة الوجبات السريعة في تجديد ال
جبة مرة أخرى.  البرغر بالجبن
وإضافة المزيد من الخضار والفاكهة والماء ولكن
دعونا لا نتخيل أن الوجبات السعيدة تتعلق فقط
بالطعام الذي يحبه الأطفال للألعاب والذي
بدأ على النحو التالي  حصلت ittle trinkets على
ترقية كبيرة بمجرد شراكة ماكدونالدز
مع علامات تجارية مثل ديزني ، ومن بين الألعاب الأكثر
شهرة
، نحل فرو الأطفال الصغير ، وقد أثبت تسويق البوكيمان مباشرة
للأطفال الذين يستخدمون ألعاب Happy Meal
نجاحًا كبيرًا ، سأكون
تكتيكًا مثيرًا للجدل بينما يستمر
في ذلك.  تطور هابي ميل لن
يغادر قائمة ماكدونالدز في أي وقت
قريب